ضجه كبيره اشعلها مقطع فيديو في السودان
مع انه الفيديو نفسه متصور فيه اريتريا
والمقطع بيظهر فيه رجل ام عم قبر محمد
احمد سرور احد عمالقه الفن والابداع في
السودان
[موسيقى]
المسيح
ما بالك
انت رايق تلعب والعشوق تعبان
الشخص اللي شفتوه رجل سوداني كان واقف عند
جبر الفنان السوداني محمد احمد سرور اللي
بيعتبر عميد الفن السوداني وتوفي عام 1947
وكان جالس بيغني كلمات احد اغاني الفنان
الراحل الشهيره وبيستخدم اله الرقه برضو
كان مشهور فيها الراحل ويبدو من المقطع
انه كان معاه شخص اخر وبيصوره المقطع
انتشر من هنا واشتغل طبعا الجدل من هنا
ناس شافت المقطع في انتهاك لحرمه الميت
وانه ما يصير الغنى في المقابر وبما انه
متعب نفسه ورايح يزور قبره في بلد تانيه
كان لازم يدعي له او يقرا القران مو يوقف
ويغني وفي ناس تانيه شافت انه لا عادي رجل
كان بيحيي ذكرى الراحل عبر فنه اللي قدمه
وفي ناس ثالثه قالت انه الجماعه الغنى
الجزائري هذا معروف كعاده او كعاده عند
السودانيين في التراث على النحو السائد في
المناحات والمراسي والاغاني الجنائزيه
والمعادي ما فيها شيء بغض النظر عن الغناء
وعن تباين الاراء اللي صايره فحقيقه يعني
ملفت في القصه وفاء الرجل لانه نحن بنتكلم
عن فنان توفي سنه 1947 يعني بنتكلم عن 77
سنه وفوق كل هذا متعني ورايح بلد تاني
اصلا يعني عشان هذه الزياره كلهم لكن على
العموم بعد الجدل الكبير هذا انتشر على
واتساب في السودان فويس نوت لرجل قال انه
هو الظاهر في الفيديو وبيرد على الجدل
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله تعالى وبركاته
انا ايوب محمد الحاج الذي غنى على غبر
الحاج محمد احمد سرور
زرت قبره بغبره باسمره رفعت له الفاتح
وترحمت عليه وقرات سوره الاخلاص 11 مره
واهدايتها الى روحي سائلا المولى ان يغفر
له ويسكنه الفردوس الاعلى
ثم غنيت اغنيه للتوسيع
ولا اكون اول من غنى على قبر سرور ماذا في
ذلك قامت الدنيا وقعدت
[موسيقى]